ང་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽རྨི་ལམ་བཏང་གི་རེད།
ངས་གྲོགས་པོ་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽རྨི་ལམ་བཏང་(ར)། གྲོགས་པོ་གིས་ང་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽རྨི་ལམ་བཏང་གི་རེད།
ང་ར་རི་འགྲམ་ལ་བསྡད་དུས་
ཁོ་རང་དེ་འགྲམ་ལ་བསྡད་དུས་དོམ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད་)(ར་)འོ་དེ་གི་
ཟླ་མཛེས་ཡོད་(བ་)འོ་དེ་རི་འགྲམ་ནས་ཡོང་(ར)། སྦྲུལ་མཉམ་དུ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ར་)
སྦྲུལ་ཁང་པ་གཅིག་མི་འདུག་གས་འོ་དེའི་ནང་ལ་འཛུལ་རེད། ཨ་ནི་ར་དོམ་དེ་(ར་)
སྦྲུལ་ཁང་པ་དེའི་ནང་ལ་རྩ་གཅིག་བླུག་
རྩ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད་)(ར་)འོ་དེའི་ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད་)(ར་)
མེ་ཏོག་ཡོད་རེད། མེ་ཏོག་དེའི་ནང་ལ་སྦྲང་རྩི་མང་པོ་དཔེ་ཡོད་རེད།
སྦྲང་རྩི་དེ་(ར་)
ཚོང་ཁང་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད་)(ར་)འོ་དེ་ལ་(ར་)
དོམ་ཡོད་(བ་)འོ་དེ་༼གིས་༽༼ཁེར་༽འགྲོ་རེད། ཨ་ནི་སྦྲལ་གཅིག་མི་འདུག་གས་འོ་དེ་ཚོང་ཁང་
དེའི་ལ་སྦྲུལ་འཛུལ་རེད། ཚོང་ཁང་དེའི་ནང་ལ་ཅ་ལག་༼གས་གུ་གཅིག་༽ཡོད་མ་རེད།
ཅ་ལག་དེ་ཚོ་བརྩལ་ག་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།་གཅིག་རྙེད་རེད་(ད)།་གཉིས་པ་དེ་ལ་རྙིད་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།གསུམ་པ་བརྩལ་ག་རེད་(ད)་
གསུམ་པ་དེ་ཡོད་མ་རེད།
ཟླ་མཛེས་དོམ་ཡོ་བ། དོམ་་གྱིས་༼ཁེར་༽འགྲོ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ང་རྒྱུགས་ཤར་གློད་དུ་(ར)། སྦྲུལ་རེད་(བ་)
རྔ་མ་དེ་ང་ཟིམ་སོང་། འོ་དེ་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽ཚར་སོང་།
ཡག་པོ་བྱུང་རེད།
[ཨི་ན་བི་ན་]༼ཁ་གྱི་༽རེད། [ཨི་ན་བི་ན་]ལ་སྐྲ་ཡོད་མ་རེད།
ང་ཚོ་ལ་སྐྲ་ཡོད་འ་འོ་
འོ་དེ་ཡོད་མ་རེད་ལབ་ཡིན། [ཨི་ན་བི་ན་]ལ་(ར་)
ཨི་ན་བི་ལ་ད་ལྟ་སླེབས་༼༼འགྲོའོ་༽༽ཡོད་རེད། ཨི་ན་བི་བ་སྐྲ་ལ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་མ་རེད།
[ཨི་ན་བི་ན་]དེ་(ར)། པ་ལགས་དང་ཨ་མ་ཡོད་མ་(ར)།  ༼འོ་༽བྱས་ནས་རེད།
པ་ལགས་དང་ཨ་མ་གྲོངས་རེད།
པ་ལགས་དང་ཨ་མ་བརླགས་ནས་གྲོངས་རེད།
ཁོང་ཚཽ་ལ་ཞི་མི་གཅིག་པོ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད།
ཞི་མི་ཁྲ་ཁྲ་སི་སི་ཡོད་རེད།
ཞི་མི་དེ་(ར་)ཉི་མ་རྟག་པར་[ཨི་ན་བི་ན་]མཉམ་དུ་འགྲོ་བསྡད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
[ཨི་ན་བི་ན་]དེ་(ར་)
སྐྲ་མེད་ན་(ར)། ཞི་མི་དེ་ཡང་སྐྲ་ཡོད་(མ་)(ར་)ཁོ་རང་ཨ་མ་ལགས་ཡོད་(བ་)འོ་དེ་འདྲ་བོ་མཐོང་གི་ཡོད་རེད། འོ་དེ་བྱས་ནས་རེད།
ཞི་མི་མིང་ག་རེ་རེད་ལབ་ན་
ཞི་མི་མིང་ར་བདེ་སྐྱིད་རེད། ཨི་ན་བི་ན༼གིས་༽བརྟགས་རེད།
ཁ་པར་ཡོད་(བ་)འོ་དེའི་ནང་ལ་ལྟ་ར་ཨ་ནི་བརྟགས་རེད།
ཨ་ནི་སྒྲུང་རྫོགས་སོང་།